let's take another question this
question again comes from the venture
capital core topic just so people are
clear I'm not a venture capital I'm a
solo practitioner angel seed investor
with a team around me and that's the way
I've designed my life but I do know a
lot about venture capitalists because
I'm associated with a couple of venture
capitalist firms and I do business with
them all the time why would a venture
capitalist fund a project like Cora
which does not generate any revenue from
ads or anything like other sites great
question Cora was founded by a rich
individual who could fund it himself
and he's playing the long game which is
he wants to put off raising money for a
long time they've done some experiments
I think in virtual currency but it's not
an expensive site to run it doesn't have
a physical product in the world like
Tesla or SpaceX or a brand list that we
had on the carpod cast or oculus so it's
a pretty the cost of running Korres
pretty low and the value it provides is
very high eventually Cora could have a
premium subscription fee where to read
the answers or to post answers you paid
I think people would pay for it ten if
Cora was ten bucks a month $100 a year
to post questions to it I think it would
pay I'm not sure what their exact
traffic is but venture capitalists love
people who play the long game and I
think the founding team came out of
Facebook if I'm if I'm correct and I'm
one of my producers looked that up and
confirmed for me that but they're
playing the long game for sure they've
been around for close to ten years now
it's closer to 10 than it is five I'm
almost certain in the Cora was founded
in 2009 maybe something in that range
Cora founding date is it in the chat
room I'll take a look yeah so 2009 right
so they're coming up with their ten-year
anniversary so they're playing the long
game and it's not the first time
somebody has you know Facebook took a
long time before they turned on their
ads same thing with the Instagram and
that's a tried-and-true practice here in
fact that's what venture capital is
designed for
so the fact that you're asking this
question why would they fund this it's
just a naive question no offense
the the reason venture capital exists is
to take these kind of crazy swings for
the fences Adam to Angelo is the the
founder he's the former Facebook CTO I
believe he he's probably put in tens of
millions of dollars of his own money so
when a founder makes a ton of money
let's say they've got two hundred
million dollars sitting in a bank
account what's sitting there so if they
want to spend 10 20 30 million dollars
on their you know passion project like
hora and then turn on revenue in the
tenth year oh my god feces love that
stuff they love that they'd love
somebody who's willing to build up and I
don't know we should take a look at what
the traffic is but I think the traffic
to Korra I'm gonna take a guess here
that Korra has 100 million visitors a
month I'm just taking a guess and I'm
gonna say more than two-thirds of that's
from America so I'll say fifty to sixty
million u.s. and somebody will look up
Korra traffic for me right now traffic
in the u.s. for Korra somebody can take
a look and see if they can find that but
I'm going to guess at least a hundred
million viewers a hundred million users
a month and we could also figure out
where they are in terms of Korra u.s.
rankings for traffic and I'm gonna guess
they would be in the top 200 maybe
anybody see that up there right now
let's take a look cody is typing
something I'm taking a quick look on
DuckDuckGo here we go
Alexa says that they are site info oh my
god as of September of this year 300
million monthly so that means they
probably have a hundred million in the
u.s. they're the 93rd largest site in
the world the 48th in the United States
that's larger than I ever thought it
would be so if they can get
let's say and it's all search engine
traffic by the way people are just
bouncing you know that's where they get
their traffic from right now it's a
search traffic was as high as 65 percent
Alexis thinking it's over 50 so it's a
very search driven site and I would put
the value of kora with 300 million I
think they could easily get 2 percent of
those people to pay so it's 300 million
uniques a month 6 million paid members
at $10 a month each or $5 a month each
would be 300 to 600 million in
subscription revenue
I could see Korra having 100 million in
subscription revenue in the first year
so let me make that just very easy math
for you $100 a year 1 million people
paying do you think there's a million
people out there who pay for Korra if I
hunt over 100 million people are paying
for Netflix I think there's a million
people who would pay for Korra I would
pay for I would pay a hundred dollars a
year for Korra five bucks a month no
problem easy peasy so that is a
fabulously naive outsider question you
obviously do not understand how the
venture business works or how rich
people think but that's fine that's why
core exists is for you to get informed
so congratulations
[Music]